(thoughtful string music)
- [Voiceover] The other
day I was looking through
old photos of me as a kid.
And it struck me how similar
my dad and I actually are.
We're both quiet, reserved.
I realized that as a kid,
my dad was the most
important person in my life.
The best part of my day was
hearing the garage open.
My brother and I would
sprint toward the door,
screaming as we jumped into his arms.
And no matter how tired from work he was,
he would pick us up,
pretending with us that
the floor was lava.
I wonder if he wishes he could
relive those moments, too.
The birthday parties, the camping trips,
trips to Sea World.
I think it's natural
for one's relationship
with their father to change over time.
It starts slowly,
you begin to spend more
time with your friends.
You start to date, move away to college.
And before you know it,
the only time that you're calling your dad
is when you start filing your taxes,
or your car is making a weird noise.
I guess somewhere along the
way I became my own person.
And then you begin to wonder,
when was the last time
that I said "I love you"?
"Thank you for the sacrifices
you made to give me
"the best life possible."
I guess he's just a phone call away.
(phone ringing)
- [Voiceover] Hello?
- [Voiceover] Hello, Father.
- [Voiceover] Hey!
- [Voiceover] I just wanted to tell you
I love you.
- [Voiceover] Oh!
- [Voiceover] And thank you,
for all that you've done.
- [Voiceover] Well, I love you, too.
That makes me very happy to
know that you have fond memories
and that you really enjoyed
spending time with me,
cus I certainly enjoyed
spending time with you.
You're coming down on Sunday?
- [Voiceover] For Father's Day, yeah.
- [Voiceover] Okay, what time
do you think you'll come over?
- [Voiceover] Probably
like in the afternoon.
- [Voiceover] Okay.